we continue to follow breaking news
tonight one person who was shot happened
at santa fe station that's near rancho
and the 95 up in the northwest valley
let's get right out to sasha loftis she
joins us now with the latest from metro
on their investigation sasha
[Music]
denise and brian this is still a very
active scene here in and outside the
casino it's kind of hard to tell because
the police officers have turned their
lights off but there are quite a few
metro police cars outside as detectives
continue to investigate now police say
this happened just after 2 30. there was
some kind of disturbance inside the
casino and a security officer was shot
multiple times a man was taken into
custody and that security officer was
taken to umc i'm told that officer is in
stable condition i asked police if
people in the area should be concerned
about this he called this a quote
isolated incident and said the hotel did
a good job keeping people safe
in this instance they were able to take
uh what potentially is a violent suspect
and detain him immediately and wait for
the police to get here so that should
give citizens a real sense of comfort to
know that in an establishment like this
they are doing their best to provide for
security
i'm told the casino is still operating
normally detectives just have a small
area blocked off for that crime scene
back out here live no one else was
reported to be hurt again no word on how
long this investigation will take inside
we're told detectives should remain here
for the next couple of hours stay with 8
news now for the very latest we'll be
here all night long we'll bring you
updates both on air and online reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now